hi I'm won a global shape up from the
lake house hobby in Nigeria I'm a radio
journalist and writer as well imagine a
question from king alex 178 and he says
what could I a high school student do to
support the economy of my country well
of course I think doing very well school
is the first thing or so you know paying
attention in class and doing really old
school so that you can get them you can
have the opportunity to and get the
right jobs and of course here and
uncreate majority but also also be an
advantage so thinking outside the box as
a high school student giorgianni if this
is the time where you have to actually
just explore ideas and think outside the
box create things invent things and of
course you never know so it could be in
there in science and engineering in the
arts and cultural fields in politics and
academia just thinking outside the box
creating new ideas and of course more
ideas needs two jobs least your tree to
give to other people learning your idea
about it and of course it's all about
making a better society and an
increasing the potential of the economy
is roller thank you